For an IBM Cloud customer it's imperative
to be able to run those workloads in the geographies
that are important to them.
The Weather Company does 250 Billion forecasts
daily.
We complete 13 Billion API calls.
We do 100 Million page views daily.
There is a lot of overhead and upkeep.
Red Hat OpenShift on IBM Cloud is fully managed
native OpenShift environment where we are
providing highly available masters, multizone
clusters, integrating with platform services
such as identity and access management, monitoring
and logging, and key protect.
It is the same OpenShift that I'm familiar
with and love so much, but the moment we moved
into the IBM Cloud all I had to worry about
was my worker nodes.
That was nice.
In terms of DevOps, the key benefit of using
a managed Kubernetes Service is that it allows
our customers to focus on innovation
and delivering software faster for their customers.
Using a managed Kubernetes service has resulted
in a 80% improvement in efficiency in my workloads
and my team's workloads because now we are
focused on what The Weather Company needs
us to focus on instead of all this infrastructure
that provided no direct benefit.
Together Red Hat and IBM are dedicated to
improving the DevOps experience of using Kubernetes.